hey reject nation it's the weekend I
guess I'm spending it here with her.she
on Easter to celebrate the resurrection
of Christ and the Easter Bunny who
raised him from the dead we're gonna do
some movie news of the week this is just
for us people we like doing and Rosa
para
she really loves these two before we do
that we wanted to say thank you to
everyone who's joined our patreon for
the month of March having so much fun
posting over there thanks guys over
there we do weekly q and A's we take a
question from patron and do a full video
response anyone who's a patron asks us a
question and the other thing too is we
do TV show reactions over there watch
along I personally cover attack on Titan
and the flash John he covers Riverdale
Marvel's runaways and Atlanta and
together recovering my hero academia
black lightning and tonight we're gonna
shoot some Jessica Jones season 2 to
finally hop onto that episode for really
dragging it out yeah just like the ship
let's hop in to some movie news of the
week we got like 7 stories here we got
to make them quick 6 stories my bad so
the first story of the week that dropped
early on donald glover and FX have exit
the plan animated Deadpool series no
actual confirmation as to what really
happened Donald Glover took some some
Twitter script stuff what did he do John
you wrote he wrote a script on Twitter
there's been a lot of arguing as to what
the direct nature of the script is a lot
of people think like it's just too
up-to-date to have been one of the
scripts from the writing process you
know for whatever creative differences
they've been having he did leak some
pages on a Twitter which I haven't
gotten to read but I've heard are very
funny and very pointed it at the Marvel
Studios I mean we have some quotes here
we're looking at colliders website
collider calm catch our live movie
trivia showdown match against the wild
berries who won you probably already
knows actually a section error that
where he said Allah for the record I
wasn't too busy to work on Deadpool
sounds like creative differences got in
the way Donald Glover wanted to make it
you know funny
and they said we don't like that tone
here's some quotes from the script pages
he leaked supposedly what it sounds like
he just wrote them you know I'm not mad
about this whole cancel thing obviously
he just wrote this I actually think it's
a good thing I mean is it even a good
time to have a violent gun loving white
man ranting on TV hard sell other than
the president I mean I get it maybe they
just want to sell toys and the style
comedy isn't it it's more ha ha but I'm
mad I get that no interesting interest
it sounds like Donald Glover wanted to
make some comedy that actually mattered
with this show
Deadpool even gets the fact that the
whole writing staff was black do you
think they canceled the show because of
racism yeah but all the writers were
black and the references were pretty
black - I heard they went over the lunch
budget what the Marvel stuff I said in
it all I said was Marvel was trying to
sell toys to seven-year-old boys and a
50 year old pedophile that's just funny
they're cool Marvel hits don't stop
there people it just feels like everyone
wants something different but nobody
wants to do anything different with it
doesn't Marvel have enough feel-good
minority shows everyone supports but
doesn't watch I mean I think our show
would have been funny I just wanted to a
place to be honest tearing up and I
guess that place is freeform experts
from the strip's manoa over we should
probably read the whole strip you all
just do a video or just read the whole
script see everything he says there live
reading dude he's pissed now seeing this
script I want to see all the other
scripts like it seems like he has a
great grip on Deadpool's tone of voice
and he would have had a different
approach to deaf people's tone of voice
which is what the show would need you
don't want something we're trying to
exactly be Ryan Reynolds as Deadpool
this would have been a different
approach and and I and I feel like this
could have even been more meta
especially with the kind of [ __ ] he's
just saying here yeah it's animated and
on FX it sounded like the perfect thing
to have it available air it there yeah a
little bummed out that's Donald Glover
for you guys the guy who gets involved
in projects that have creative
differences hey we just talked about
some Marvel let's talk about some DC
stuff Oh guess what guys we haven't seen
an Aquaman trailer yet what what what
and you know what's something to say
about that
Jimmy watch Jimmy one just said hey
friends hi friends I usually do my best
to avoid internet noises specially
fabricated distractions John story
judging my Australian voice Jesus really
going out this week and was never in the
books despite what some claim it's not
because of any one or any nefarious
reason holding it back it's my oh man Oh
taking responsibility oh I'm simply not
ready to get to share this movie is
filled to the gills half Neil's VFX and
the process is slow and laborious like C
/ haha puns yes even shots for the
trailers take forever to do and I refuse
to put out anything that might be
construed is subpar I know it seemed
like nothing much to do an impression
yeah yeah earning points diversity I
know it seems like nothing much is
brewing above the surface but I can
assure you already non-stop under the
weights I hope this is how the script
yes I plan to use oceanic puns
references every chance I get
you know John TC is probably playing it
smart for the lackluster box-office
response to Justice League and the
lackluster critical and audience
response to most everything else they've
it's probably best to wait till the VFX
is complete on the trailer
I actually haven't seen any movie news
on this but I'm sure a Campea or Merle
or a harloff has probably said something
like that and yeah they're all
absolutely right okay you can go down
this is smart move on James Bond's idea
it's like you want to introduce this
well and especially when the idea of
doing this underwater movie which sounds
so hard to do you've got to make sure
that the first time you're presenting
footage will be whoa I gotta see that
even if it's just for the effects yeah
you gotta make a good impression the
first teaser trailer is not gonna have
to sell you on the story it's gonna have
to sell you on the world and if the
world looks believable and then you can
be engrossed in it so yeah dude take
your time
wait till November if you want I don't
care just get it right I've heard some
speculation that you know they probably
want to wait till after infinity war and
that seems like a smart idea because
just anything superhero you put out
before then it was just gonna get
crushed under the weight of all that
hype and James Bond man he seems like a
smart sharp filmmaker I believe this
coming from him I don't really have any
trouble accepting this like yeah this is
another cover-up took the DCU is in
trouble I don't think so yeah my my
compass insights isn't that John oh boys
more Wonder Woman news ooh what's in
what's new what's new with the Wonder
Woman the guy who got his head smashed
in in Game of Thrones oh yes I'm pretty
sure is the only thing he's known for
yeah nothing else nothing else nothing
recent is DQ wood can have a better
career
Pedro Pascoe who you guys might know
from Kingsman the Golden Circle
narcos and the equalizer - oh yeah yeah
we've all seen that already most
definitely I have do we know who he's
gonna play yeah he's gonna play Wonder
Boy oh thank god well yeah we have no
idea who paid your apostle's gonna play
well you know John it's a movie news
segment we should probably talk about
you know how Pedro Pascal is a good
actor who's good actor yeah what woman's
about you know about diversity mm-hmm
Pedro Pascal being from Latino or
Mexican or Hispanic or whatever the
proper word is yeah he's not just a
white dude that in Chris Pine bodes well
for a diverse film sure so yeah keep the
diversity train rolling
Pascal is it is a pretty damn good
doesn't give me much other than oh good
another good actor will be in this yeah
I'm so excited to watch Pedro Pascal and
Kristen Wiig bounce off each other yeah
definitely bringing those comedy chops
to the dream team oh look out now my man
simon Pegg's
spouting off some some shade right now
he mad this is the month where
celebrities get mad at studios diversity
Gausman all I think it was poorly
marketed to be honest if you look at a
film like Suicide Squad that was around
for such a long time before I finally
came out of people were so aware of it
whereas what's tortured Beyond he was
left too late before they started the
marketing push it's such a great
business but it was disappointing
compared to into darkness I was really
angry about that because it used
sabotage which was a surprise moment at
the end it was supposed to be very fun
and heightened twist at someone that's
something I can do and something that
was a big surprise and they blew it in
the first trailer which really annoyed
me they also made the film look like a
boneheaded action film and they were
scared I think of mentioning the 50th
anniversary it was fumbled as a thing
they didn't know what to do with it and
it's a real shame but I came away from
it really really happy and very proud of
it but really I liked the film but you
guys about the gate you know I did not
think beyond look that good honestly I
don't really remember beyond I remember
people really like Star Trek beyond I
remember liking it but yeah I don't I I
remembered the stuff I saw the truth
I remember the trailer better than I do
the movie yeah and I remember liking
that the movie and I remember people
saying the movie was a little more
toward this Star Trek end of the
spectrum for real and yeah like sabotage
would have been a fun surprise or
whatever I don't know I guess I get why
he's mad at the same time that trailer
caught everybody's attention so well why
sabotage a big deal again because it was
like Chris Pine is his James T Kurtz
intro song in the first one or something
when he's a little kid I was that it
I don't know oh cool oh yeah yeah
something about that has been being
reprised me I do some research guys
through the power of YouTube John and I
found the first scene James Tiberius
Kirk was introduced in the Star Trek
reboot yes it was the sabotage song I
guess if you're like a hardcore fan of
the reboot that's a big surprise if I
really remembered that from this yeah
that would have been a really cool
callback as it stood there at least in
terms of advertising I was just like oh
this isn't the town I was expecting for
a Star Trek trailer yeah I agree it
looked like a boneheaded action film
look dumb
it looks like Man Star Trek is not Star
Trek anymore just some silly action fest
one Simon Pegg being behind the script
and it has like really good dialogue in
that film I remember it's like really
witty with its script and none of that
is really showcasing the trailers beyond
was poorly marketed however Star Trek is
a franchise where they're always been up
and down with their movies box office or
critical reception it's always been that
way always who makes Star Trek Paramount
now is that they're they the studio DC
no I was gonna say I got I like the more
I think about the recent Star Trek
movies the more I get that like you know
Zack Snyder really seems like he wants
to make a Batman movie and I feel like
these guys really want to make Star Wars
movie but you know they got Star Trek
instead so we're gonna make the most out
of that yeah you know because the whole
struggle of this new franchise has been
like it's kind of getting back towards
what made it Star Trek kind of I know
vagary simon pegg marc amiel revealed
that George Lucas was the one behind the
sequel saga originally we're not done
talking about the last ship I'm not
tired of and afraid I happen to know
that George didn't kill Luke until the
end of episode 9 after he trained Leia
which is another thread that was never
played upon in the last Jedi George
he had an overall arc if he didn't have
all the details he's sort of an overall
feel of where the sequel trilogy was
going but this one's more like a relay
race
you run in hand and torch off the next
guy he picks it up and goes Ryan didn't
write what happens in nine he was gonna
hand it off originally Colin Trevorrow
and now JJ it's an ever-evolving living
breathing thing whoever's on board gets
to play with the life-sized action
figures that we all are wow sounds like
Star Wars is really just a movie made
from studios and not what people think
it is yeah some like Grand High brains
spits out the next installment or yeah
I've completely forgot did we hear that
Colin Trevorrow was supposed to do the
names eventually yes that would it be
cool I have no idea how Star Wars fans
have responded to what Mark Hamill has
said here one side of me goes there's
probably a large people were like dude
that would have been so much better oh
yeah I'm sure this is only fueling the
the hatred of the last Jedi and also
fueling the the backlash of like store
worthless to change and I think to that
I don't think George Lucas probably
would have done a good job honestly um
maybe what makes you say that
well he did American Graffiti and he
created a new hope the terrible films
after that most of the movies he did
were pretty good pretty great those two
just really put a bad taste in my head
man doesn't spoil a bad transition Hey
look his back speaking of college for a
Varro Jurassic world 3 now has a
director it's Colin Trevorrow this is
how I felt when I learned that JJ Abrams
is gonna direct Sierra's episode 9 maybe
a little more in the Oh side of the
spectrum Trevorrow is the JJ Abrams of
Tourette's and shavar Oh God JJ doubt on
Star Wars yeah the second one and who is
he replacing who was supposed to do the
third matter josh trank was supposed to
do the third one they're like no we
gotta call it J Breanna
John boyega ojj Bayona my biology a
banana
hey there's a thing here about how
Chaparro way back when mapped out of
three movie art yes absolutely I know
where I wanted to go I remember telling
Stevie spill BIG's even while we were
still making the first movie this is the
beginning here's the middle and here's
the end of the end
that's how trilogies work this is where
we want to go I feel like that kind of
design is crucial to a franchise like
this if you really want to bring people
along with you and make sure they stay
interested that's true man there's a lot
of depth to this trilogy it needs to be
thought through on that level absolutely
and I really feel like the first movie
and then the trailers - the second one
or really get exemplary of the Exide
doesn't just look like a cash grab for
more dinosaur action they can't be a
contestant Hartman - a character based
franchise totally its overall turning in
full with people who you lean into
follow what they're going to do oh my
god the internal conflicts and the
motives at the end of this movie it's
not a cliffhanger but it's designed for
people who want to know what's gonna
happen next whereas the earlier Jurassic
Park movies in pretty clear definitive
ending they were pretty much episodic in
working with Derek Connolly my co-writer
we were also thinking about where it was
going to go in the future I mean this
makes more sense to get your Varro back
as opposed to Jay a boy but I felt like
Jay had like a whole special idea for
what he wanted Jurassic world to be in
the fact they're going back to the first
director that kind of just makes you do
the head scratch and go maybe they're
not so confident or maybe they're like
we don't want to get too different from
yeah I got weirdly that that that idea
almost from the Star Wars decision if
he's like saying [ __ ] like yeah like I
like the concept of what he's talking
about here and I'm all for making our
fun blockbusters you know better films
sure the first movie isn't really
exemplary of these things to me I mean
the first movies always end with maybe
we shouldn't have
servers anymore and then the the
trailers for the new ones and
essentially the openings for the new
ones go dinosaurs were taken overnight
out again what different [ __ ] he's
talking about that Jurassic world has
opened this landscape forward especially
because they're all in the same universe
and like if that's true I just gotta
believe that like it it's a world where
all humans are kind of thick cuz like
this has been a bad idea every time yeah
he's like talking about making a
character based franchise I love the way
whatever her name was was super into her
job and nothing else and that was all
her character was yes I'm saying like
fallen Kingdom better represents some of
whatever you're talking about where it
ends in a way where I'm like yeah I
wanna I want to see this conclude
there's something I don't know or at
least it just gets me excited to see it
again and not weary Jurassic world kind
of makes me weary about Jurassic world
too and that's not how I wanted to feel
at all I hated your characters and
that's that's why I don't like that
movie so much I'm like the fun stuff is
great and the characters kind of suck my
favorite scene out of the first Jurassic
Park is when they're all at the table
after they've all learned about
dinosaurs and Jeff Goldblum dr. Malcolm
is bringing up everything that could go
wrong about this and they're having a
really strong debate and the let's see
who's the guy who opened up the Hammond
yeah yeah yeah Richard Attenborough yeah
when he went there when they debris no
no here's why it's a good idea when I
heard that scene always makes me go you
know I I see both of their first but is
really well yeah and there's an element
of science to the science fiction yeah
and that's not design here is a
commentary I don't know I don't know
maybe maybe it'll be good and I mean the
indominus rex thing like borders on that
but mostly the point of that becomes
cynicism over anything because they're
like people want a bigger scarier
dinosaur and I'm like you don't have to
be brilliant to know that this is a
terrible idea
like the t-rex broke out and and and
made some bigger than that like what
science anybody no alright well guys
that's our movie news of the week which
story here stood out to you the most do
you wish the Deadpool animated series
was still happening are you pissed that
we still haven't gotten an Aquaman
trailer when the movie is only eight
months away Wonder Woman to cast Pedro
Pascal are you from the Latino heritage
and you were excited for this Simon Pegg
do you agree with the marketing made you
like beyond Mark Hamill George Lucas's
would have been better am i right and
Jurassic world three oh boy the
mythology guys you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
about they get notified whenever a video
of ours is up and hey check us out on
patreon